[Musik]
hinter den dicken mauern des
benediktinerklosters engelberg tut sich
an diesem winter wochenende und erhöhtes
[Musik]
wer vor ihnen nimmt auch kultur und
regelmäßig
kkr ist somit jetzt
und bei sony zeigt bis der summe jetzt
[Musik]
sie nennen sich britta auf zeit sie
wollen über ihr mann sein reden ganz
unter sich sie die teilnehmer im seminar
gipfeltreffen ganz man sein ein
wochenende lang wollen sie frei sein von
den ansprüchen ihrer frauen und
vorgesetzten wollen das rollenkonzept
ablegen müsse die gesellschaft denkt ihr
ziel zwei tage lang ganz mahnt sein
[Musik]
sie waren frisst sich als auch jetzt
nämlich eine schleife marco carini
beschäftigt sich mit dem menschlichen
bewegungsapparat seit ausbruch der
finanzkrise im jahr 2008 musste sich aus
arzt aber immer häufiger auch um
verletzte männer zählen kümmern ich habe
schon vorher sagt praxis kam ich an
einer hand abzählen trotz der momentanen
uns bericht und plötzlich ist das buch
endlich
passiert phase wie es fast zwei tage
pausiert und durch mir einfach gefallen
zu haben und das umfeld das in meiner
sind plötzlich noch viel mehr unter
druck leistungsdruck
arbeitsplatzsicherheit zentral dass ich
noch 208 richtig los brauchen wir
langsam richtig dabei wie ist das doch
die angst fährt den männern in die
knochen in marco carini entstand die
idee einen einen ort zu bieten an denen
heilsame gespräche unter ihresgleichen
stadt fühlen können ich glaube die
vorstellung dass man sich nicht
mitteilen
die stimmt nur drin wenn man's man's
halt net bietet aber immer der mann
seitdem gibt oder sie sich einigermaßen
wohl fühlt dann redet sie und ich glaube
sie reden so viel wie frauen redet oder
gar keine gender unterschied aber
schwellen ist einfach hören dass sie
offen rede
die abgeschiedenheit eines
benediktinerklosters soll den männern in
diesen rahmen bieten
[Musik]
die befragung von panik von ihm arzt am
jahre alter
körperlich ausgelaugt und
seit märz ist neugier wie es
untereinander also gott und der artikel
schon mal als lehrer mit
meersalz besseren score also wir jetzt
auch im kreis
das nächste fest dass sie jetzt
plötzlich überhaupt zu erlassen oder
sind so sachen vovo völlig neu sind
okay
ich gerade
spiele
[Musik]
für unsere generation deutscher brat mir
definiert für heute sind 12 mann zitiert
und damit um und ich hoffe ich suche
nach dem was kann ich für
mich alltag ganz auswahl finden aber
wichtig dass man sich
so eine temporäre bruderschaft
zurückziehen und themen ganz unter sich
diskutieren
auch wenn der co leiter des seminars
reformierter pfarrer ist um religion
geht es nicht an diesem gipfeltreffen
wohl aber und spiritualität
den männern sollen neue wege zu körper
seele und geist aufgezeigt werden
sie vor dem gipfel grafisch ganz nah
sein was heißt es ist also prima mal
wirklich einer gruseligen
indirekte die netz bringen wo wir sehr
langsam druck machten und machen wollte
klassische rollenbild von der fck so
mancher ps-starke schlacht und wo jetzt
ja dank der letzten 40 jahre man
situation sondern eine zusätzliche
komponente projekt hat und das ist die
übliche sind die wie keine verträge aber
auch nix haltiger und eigeninteresse er
sollte sagen ihr frage sind sie schnell
auf die überholspuren für uns mut
gemacht und ist im job wieder vorne
beugen
so richtig passiert
station 1 auf der reise zu einem neuen
männerbild das modul bedürfnis kompetenz
unter der leitung von scheidungsanwalt
petkovic lernen die seminarteilnehmer
ihre bedürfnisse zu erkennen und zu
kommunizieren
zum beispiel in konfliktsituationen und
legt es ist das wenn man sie lustvoll
aktiv dass man das sicher mehr kompetenz
dazu
gelegentlich wie wie gar nicht selber
mit konflikt- und jede für euch mit
konflikt um grundsatz ich bin ja noch 36
orientiert die mensch und
mehreren faktoren fetisch und lösungen
nach möglichkeit den konflikt diesem tag
für mich ist größten frieden und ruhe
mich beruflich uns damit beschäftigen
konflikt lösen so sich froh gehen man
nicht verordnen um uns entsprechend zu
kaufen bin und immer wieder feststellen
dass meine frau problem ich bin früher
sich um den sprachen kommt sie dann viel
mehr auf mich zu haus ungeklärt
was ich dann was mich dann ziemlich
unter druck gesetzt was sie gern
ruhig bin
gestresst fühlen
beziehungs business as usual
auch wenn es tatsächlich ungewohnt ist
dass männer so offen über ihre gefühle
reden beim thema bedürfnis kompetenz
werden auch sexuelle bedürfnisse schnell
zum thema
große kompetenz was rede also überhaupt
miteinander ins gespräch auch ganze
sache sind avisiert
offen emotionale roten und sexuelle will
ich sowieso mannheim gleich spruch klärt
darüber ganz viel bauch eine nicht
miteinander darüber reden einst war
vielleicht gut funktionieren sechs habe
aber sie sind nicht grüßt das für ein
moment wo eine bedürfnisse nicht
mitteilen ist nicht mehr so läuft wird
das jetzt vorgestellte um redeten nicht
miteinander
denn ganz im
sinne bedürfnissen und in sicht sich
hinter einer authentisch kabine ich
halte nicht viel davon dass moment
bilder zeichnen dann probiere noch
zu
warten oder ganz zärtlich liebevolle
fürsorge und husmann die stadt das sind
jeder für sich muss machen und in dieser
rolle wirklich gut werde nur noch selber
will ja und wo sind die kompetenzen für
sich zu finden
ein wochenende lang sollen sich die
brüder auf zeit nicht über ihre leistung
definieren darum kein fußball match
sondern yoga
man sehr große bewältigt defizit
koordinative defizit und eine unbedingt
fähigkeit sich zu entspannen dank radio
eindeutiger war das schon mal noch
exzellent sein sagt zum teil oder
überhaupt nicht entdeckt
[Applaus]
wir möchten eigentlich vor allem
mitmachen mitmachen und sage zu viele
man schon gemacht haben will ich glaube
sie haben vieles gut gemacht nicht alles
wir möchten aber mut machen sich
vielleicht 19 decke stecke
die rote flora eines spruchs fin de vito
mit ihren
lebenspartner partnerin mit ihren kinder
und medien
arbeitsumgebung
kommunikation wieder neu zu erwecken
oder für sich sah sich das freizeit
hobby
neu ist auch ein deckel oder was ist
schon lange machen nur zu haben dass
andere umsätzen und niedrigen wir auf
pension jährig zu beachten oder biskind
groß sind oder was erwin
liebe mitbrüder
können wir jetzt so
[Musik]
wurden die was sie schon immer eine frau
fragen wollten und nie zu fragen trauten
doch vorstellen onkel
am samstag abel gesetzlich vorübergehend
eine zweite frau in die männerrunde maya
onken hat zusammen mit marco carini die
so genannte mann erklärte mir gegründet
die autofahrer jetzt 20 jahre frauen
branche wie viel macht
und es ist mir einfach salik dass die
man auf die partner für deine frauen auf
die strecke geblieben es ich habe es für
das paar relativ schwierig eine frau
große entwicklung durchgemacht und
feuerwehr weil ich detail bringt oder
methoden hoffer hat zum gespräch führen
oder
konfliktlöser unter magersucht moment
wie stahl bleibt
beim letzten gipfeltreffen wurde maya
onken zu jeder erdenklichen facetten der
weiblichen sexualität befragt heute gibt
man sich politisch korrekt
sind ihre beziehung immer wichtiger sei
es verlernt hast du das rezept
also rezept hat wirklich aber ich habe
so
eine idee was frauen a mix macht und man
könnte durchaus tarife ich weiß aber
bewusst ist dass eure frauen ständig
obwohl er vielleicht meine die
seegebiete finanzen mit sobald ein
kontostand überführt
und da ich nicht effektiv esa lehrbuch
sondern alles was ihr könnt oder wasser
eben nicht und wird kommentiert also ein
blumenstrauß +5 zu punkt
vergessen opensuse träge - 20 ein nettes
wort am abend statt sie wie hashes ko
plus 100 m kraul es norbert schatz sk -
und frau sei geplant die säcke einfach
nur ihr hängt das ja schon lange - sie
sind sie hoffe ja noch les das dauert
bis rund um ein bus der evag und dem
präsentiert sie ihr kontostand und der
ist einfach absolut den - und das ist
nicht der punkt wo noch heute die griffe
die demo eure frauen vc marl die steg
unterstand so aktuell wie dir und da
gibt eigentlich da wenn ich so scharf
und geld am end von monat einbringen wie
viel die stirn erwärmt und dann würdet
ihr eure bewundere meine weniger
unterschiedlich kommentiert
meine dreimal er immer sei der logische
und danisco
beispiel farben sowie wind permanente
erneuerung
permanenten beschuss
[Musik]
heute morgen männer willkommen zu
unserem live gebracht in der jüdisch
christliche tradition nenne mir
und der ort im wind als das wort für
gott heißt alle
drohten besonders wenn es in im körper
mit läufen unterstütze lange
werde unterbrochen in unserer
wirklichkeit begegnen gott das heißt
gebet
[Musik]
eine auszeit vom alltag gespräche mit
gleichgesinnten reflexion und
neuausrichtung eine gute sache auch wenn
diese anlass eigentlich genauso gut ganz
mensch sein heißen könnte
offenbar funktioniert der austausch
unter männern aber besser als in
gemischten gruppen
das ist den teilnehmern etwas wert knapp
1200 franken bezahlen die für dieses
verlängerte wochenende
martin luther zeit zweimal in der woche
macht im jahr 104 schadet weder tier
noch mehr
ich glaube das ist es warum sexuelle
gesundheit in der interaktion slime und
besucher so und jetzt darf ich euch
bitte minute die b 62 lag minutenlang
entschlossenen aber was ist für ihn
sexualität
seiner schwierigsten ist allererste
schritt tage warm mal unsere sexualität
definieren wenn beide mit gewisse
blockade sind denk- und bisher kaum
diskussion und da kann man wirklich ganz
vorsichtig fahren und sagen wir machen
jetzt sexualität das spielfeld
und alles was nicht in frage kommt mini
persönlichen note aus schrieb das
spielfeld und das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass ich die je im himmel ab
und braucht den hit run dreifacher klar
das nimmt langsam oben aber es kann
sogar sehr produktiver als lustig machen
roth die schwarten ende geschrieben
wichtig ist die sexuelle fantasien
und das spielfeld willkommen zone machen
und hat speziell dass wir die wirklich
nicht verzichten und in der nabe zone
das ist verhandelbar sexualität muss man
einfach handle weil es meiner verhandelt
es neben mir alles war darum haben wir
ihn darin industrie so unglaubliche
umsatz ich würde auf die luftfahrt ist
am
ludwigsplatz zu machen das spiel fand
eine zweite frage in der beziehung 3 etc
geiles langes küssen und dabei geblasen
werden
sex mit mehreren räumen gleichzeitig und
ausdauer
richtig vom leder ziehen am küchentisch
bei offenem fenster
nicht immer ging es an diesem
gipfeltreffen so frivol und flapsig zu
es gab workshops wo geweint und
getröstet wurde etwa dann wenn einige
seminarteilnehmer über ihre väter
erzählten bei diesen programmpunkten
waren die männer wirklich unter sich
ohne kamera
[Musik]
eine starke emotionale eruptionen
elektro immer mehr überrascht worden und
das ist sehr gut drauf gewartet weit
wortgruppen das pint bier für das ist
ein teil format und eine truhe texas
besprechungsraum organe trainer oder
dass sie auch das ständige wache wo ich
gemerkt das muss jetzt wieder aber dass
das mit der geschädigte spaziert florida
im rahmen mit einem anderen mann
es geht wie man das und jetzt geschichte
gehört
viel extremere problem kann und andere
sorgen
[Musik]
und auch wenn das gegenüber stellen dann
ist das einfach alles alles auf die
relativ mini problem was ist das was sie
ab monieren
nicht erst morgen
sonderlich auf das haben wir aber
dennoch
sehr wichtig was ich habe gespürt
was mir gut tut ist bewegung also ich
habe erstmal im labor gemacht und hoffe
ich gar nicht so schlecht macht und das
spüren dass du gut
[Musik]
dass versuche dort setzte mit
punktesystem eine geniale funde und die
wird sicher eine firmensprecherin
kontostand ist
jeder teilnehmer erlebte am
gipfeltreffen seinen persönlichen
höhepunkt derjenige der reporterin kam
ganz zum schluss beim
beckenbodentraining für mensch
dass der ausbau nicht was ich einfluss
so vermischt man
jetzt immer noch so genau die portals
punkte moleküle empfehlenswert rosen zu
machen
höhepunkt von zwischen skulptur zu den
roten zahlen
mit
gewissen nachdruck auf den punkt danke
[Musik]
so sind zwar jetzt schon erreicht er
oben gehalten der verkauf wie trinken
müsste trainieren immer
machen sie schluss dass die position des
löwen aus dem fernen heimat vor
jetzt hat auch gesagt
[Applaus]
[Musik]